il ya les gens qui rêvent de changer de
rythme et il ya ceux qui comme moi
d'essayer de le faire
lui c'est le mon meilleur ami cadeaux
ils habitent à los angeles depuis 5 ans
ou trois ans et sexuellement décès des
bébés je suis yoga les thérapies pour
finir sur des applications q quand même
j'ai trouvé lui pour demain soir ouais
c'est comme les crêpes et des lapins et
toujours phare est obligé de l'allemand
jette sur la première crèche
je pense trop à la française monde
s'inquiète c'est quand même un avion de
chasse jane connors
sortir un peu la déshabiller là qu'on
voudrait laisser faire le destin si
cendrillon l'avait laissée par le destin
elle sera encore au travers des ménages
chez sa belle-mère et a parlé à des
petites souris c'est tellement génial
d'être anonyme de coucher avec un
anonyme
c'est juste une autre façon d'être
spirituel en fait c'était très physique
a quand même hein
[Musique]